what's up guys
bang bang lunch money time
big news we're coming to you live
from the new studio no more kitchen
we still got some work to do we still
got some work to do gotta get a little
backdrop
gotta get the microphones working but we
got lights we got you
we're ready to rock and roll with lunch
money while while
she's trying to get rich the rest of us
trying to get our lunch money right i'm
sad that the instant pot was rejected as
a possible
backdrop no we ain't got time nobody got
time for no
instant pot all right so let's get into
today but first
blockfi is a sponsor they've got three
products you can buy and sell
crypto on their new crypto exchange you
can deposit crypto
and earn up to 8.6 apy in their interest
bearing accounts
my favorite product i'm an investor of
the company and a user of the product
uh and then you can also deposit crypto
and take out a us dollar loan against
your collateral
go to blockfi.com lunch money or click
on the link in the description
no-brainer interest bearing accounts to
pay up to 8.6
apy are quite attractive all right
what's up with fortune global 500.
that different than fortune 500 yes okay
the fortune 500
ranks companies the the top 500
companies by revenue in the united
states
the fortune global 500 ranks them by
revenue
around the world okay the list is out
this morning my hair looks real crazy go
ahead
the list oh don't do that
the list is out this morning and
for the first time in history this is a
really big deal
there are more fortune 500 companies
based in
man mainland china and hong kong than in
the us
for the first time in history there are
124 companies
and mainly in china and hong kong versus
121 in the u.s
if you add in taiwan the total jumps to
133 if that's a whole other issue
interesting so just know that being on
the list is no guarantee of
profitability
because it ranks them by revenue and um
you know many of the companies aren't
necessarily
the chinese companies aren't necessarily
on there because of their business
diamond
dynamism but because there are
state-supported monopolies in the
world's largest market
all right two things one we have no clue
if any of the metrics are correct in
china
i'm not claiming that i know of any that
are not correct but we have seen in the
past
uh there's a great movie with carson
block um and
a number of other documentaries where
there's a lot of shenanigans that go on
um in east asia uh
countries with these companies now let's
take it at face value and say that all
the metrics are correct
uh there is no doubt that there
is um in the eastern part of the world a
rise
in terms of economic uh prosperity is
there a rise in
innovation uh some would argue that
they've literally just taken the ideas
and stolen the ip
uh the intellectual property of uh the
western world
and now they're just using it to their
advantage others would argue no there
actually is innovation going on
i'll leave that for anyone else to uh to
kind of figure out
but um i think that it's just natural
you're gonna get this kind of pendulum
swing right you're gonna see sometimes
uh there's gonna be way more in the u.s
historically that's where it's been um
but then you're gonna see it swing back
and if you go back you know hundreds of
years obviously the us wasn't the leader
because the us didn't even really exist
but now you're seeing kind of the swing
back to uh to eastern countries
it's about 50 50 right now right so it's
not necessarily like
it's out um outweighing on one side or
the other
uh and that's probably pretty healthy i
think it's
healthy for global competition i don't
know if it's a good thing that
mainland china has uh bigger companies
than the us
but my big thing is do they
all right what's going on with jimmy let
is it lay live i think it's lay lay all
right what's up with jimmy
so i first found out about jimmy lay
last august
august 2019 when he had a big profile in
bloomberg
about being a media tycoon in hong kong
who was
very pro-democracy he had sent his
reporters to the front lines of the
protests and the riots and
he's he's just been a thorn in china's
side for a very long time mainland china
now uh jimmy lei known for
his support of the city's pro-democracy
movement and criticism of china has been
arrested on
suspicion of colluding with foreign
forces so he's been basically um
arrested under that new national
security law
imposed on the city by beijing last
month
is there a free press they keep saying
there is doesn't look like it
not anymore well does it look like it
i just my whole point with all of this
is
as much as i rail against the issues of
the mainstream media
as much as i rail against all of the
issues with clickbait journalism all
that kind of stuff
remember there's a free press and when
you have free press
there are significant advantages uh and
one of them
is that they can say the things that are
unpopular they can say the things that
they believe to be true they can serve
as a kind of a gut check or yeah a
watchdog
on those in power right and so when you
start arresting reporters
it's not good and there's also there's
not a fear that what you report on
might get you arrested or have your car
blown up or things like that that you
see in other countries that
it's quite scary apparently but oh
i also believe that if reporters break
the law
they should be required to go to jail
just like anybody else and so there is a
fine line and this is a very fine line
similar to the police who receive
immunity
if they break the law in many cases
right that they're immune because they
just say oh i'm a police officer like i
was doing my job
well there needs to be checks and so i'm
actually of the belief that you should
have freedom of press
but there should be penalty when you get
things wrong so
there have been examples in history
where certain publications like
the stephen glass case he worked for
this publication where he published a
number of fabricated
cover stories for them he was caught he
got in trouble the publication kind of
like went away but he was
caught by another journalist so i think
you know
there's checks and balances did he get
in trouble yeah what
he got fired and i think there was legal
repercussions yeah like that's fine like
you don't
have to be like a jail thing it doesn't
have to be like a quote-unquote crime
thing necessarily
but just like there has to be some sort
of
punishment uh or or penalty when
you do things especially with
maliciousness especially
especially it's one thing if you just do
it out of uh
by accident or you you didn't think it
was correct right
it's another thing when you like uh the
guy at buzzfeed
who i don't know if you guys remember
there's a guy at buzzfeed who buzzfeed
supposedly came out and were like oh we
found all these articles that have been
plagiarized
i think the guy like says his job and is
like perfect i don't know i don't think
so
in in in general so to prove somebody
did something you have to prove
malicious intent which is very difficult
but
it is not you know impossible um
wait the other thing is for jimmy lay
they basically arrested him
in the newsroom and took him out in
handcuffs and his reporters began
videoing and like doing journalism uh
but it's just pretty crazy
okay do you think they want it then like
obviously they do that because they
wanted it on the news
it's a scare tactic for who well not a
scare tactic i think they were just
doing their job
all right what's up with twitter twitter
has approached tick tocks chinese owner
bite dance to
express interest in acquiring the us
operations of the video sharing app what
do we think about
that i think that it would be
irresponsible of any large technology
company right now not to kind of kick
the tires a little bit and say hey you
know what do you got how much do you
want for it
what exactly would it look like with if
you divested up this asset
how much staff would we take on what are
the cost to operate this is it
profitable is it not what your revenue
look like what are your projections in
the future about advertising revenue
like you want to just kind of understand
what's going on so if you're a large
technology company like to me it seems
kind of a no-brainer that you would
um you'd be kicking the can or kicking
the tires
but do you remember
twitter once on vine and i saw somebody
online that said
how ridiculous and crazy would it be if
twitter shut down
vine only to turn around within two to
three years and buy
tick tock for 30 billion also unlikely
because i think twitter's market cap if
i remember correctly
is like 25 or 30 billion so you would
basically have to double the size of
your market cap in order to make the
purchase
and so what you would have to do is
either issue a ton of shares uh or
two you'd have to go do something from a
financing standpoint to even have the
capital
can i ask a question that to me is
ridiculously obvious but nobody seems to
be asking
sure okay twitter and microsoft have
been
rumored or not rumored in some cases
confirmed to be expressing interest
in buying tick-tock why the hell
is facebook not expressing interest
uh well a couple of things one is they
probably have and just not been reported
and two is to me that's the obvious
no-brainer
yeah this is a wild tape but i think
that they're going to uh
beat tick-tock we'll see yeah i i think
that
uh if you allow this to play out long
enough i think
facebook when they did instagram stories
realized the playbook so historically
facebook
has pursued one of two strategies either
they buy you or
if they want to compete with you they
try to create like their own standalone
applications
and that very quickly became obvious
like that's not a thing
now what they've realized with instagram
stories is wait why don't we take the
functionality of a different application
and merely uh incorporate it into one of
our core properties
um so they did facebook stories they did
instagram
stories uh and those have been wild
successes and drastically now
um kind of outperform in usage uh the
competitor snapchat
and so i think that what you end up
seeing here is they just released
instagram reels they're going to make
that into the product literally you find
it right in the feed
and the whole idea is what tick tock had
uh
in terms of its functionality was set
behind
a big wall of friction that wall of
friction was you had to go download a
new application you had to sign up for
an account you had to figure it out you
had to build a new law
you have to sign up for an account to
use an issue
to like create content to create right
yeah and that's not necessarily just to
consume
but the whole idea is then you've got to
build your own audience you gotta like
do all this kind of stuff
now if they can simply take that
functionality and they can bolt it into
instagram there's a lot of people who
say rather than go start a whole new
thing where i got to build a whole new
audience
instead i can just do this here and i
think what you're going to see is an
explosion of usage of that product and
if you guys remember a lot of these
celebrities
traditional celebrities that we consider
you know well known
in the media today they had a hard time
building
um followings on tick tock because they
had to start over but this way if it's
on instagram they already have their
built-in audience
it's much easier for them to just create
content and have it go
viral all right what's up with wendy's
all right
wendy's mcdonald's is better well
wendy's is eating mcdonald's breakfast
what's on march 2nd wendy's finally
launched its highly anticipated
breakfast menu nationwide and then two
weeks later the morning commute
collapsed because of covet yet
breakfast now accounts for eight percent
of wendy's total sales
a figure the fast food chain is
celebrating because i hoped it would
amount to 10 of total sales
by the end of the year what is the
market share of
breakfast eating at fast food
restaurants that wendy's has versus
mcdonald's my guess is that mcdonald's
is so far ahead they can't even see when
you're in the rearview mirror apparently
apparently mcdonald's has been
struggling
well yeah pandemic shut down right but
wendy's breakfast because okay so it has
some really weird unlike unlike
mcdonald's and all the other ones
that's kind of a weird breakfast like it
has the breakfast baconator and the
frosty chino
like who is getting that for breakfast
but it seems to be working so mcdonald's
is still bigger
i don't know so in fact when he's not
eating mcdonald's just breakfast
i don't know it is merely i know
okay i read the internet and instead
what you end up finding
is that mcdonald's is uh merely looking
at wendy's and saying
good try good try mcdonald's salesman
you want to know what mcdonald's you
want to know what mcdonald's came out
with a while ago that was an absolute
game changer i had a couple times
mcgriddles
if you've ever had a mcgriddle leave a
comment and i'll go through and i'll
respond to you about the mcgriddles
because those things are dangerous
at mcdonald's for lunch what's going on
with education
all right so uh power duo
michelle obama and melinda gates wrote a
joint op-ed in cnn today
no not today a few days ago whoops um
but basically
they're saying like a lot of schools
worldwide due to covet won't come back
in person and that endangers a lot of
kids
education but especially those of
adolescent girls
so even before covent 19 struck more
than 98 million
adolescent girls worldwide were not in
school
now due to ripple effects from the
pandemic the malala fund predicts an
additional 20 million girls of secondary
school age could remain
out of school and that's you know uh
melinda and michelle are arguing that
this is a risk to their safety and
security
because during crisis like this
adolescent girls face a heightened
threat of physical and sexual violence
early enforced marriage and unintended
pregnancy on top of sustained economic
hardship
so now they're teaming up and they're um
they are um helping
with resources to con continue their
education online
and they're doing something like there's
organizations like the sacred valley
project in peru
and kenya's dream in kenya and they have
developed innovative solutions
uh to give girls like radios and printed
materials to help them learn
first question do we think that they
actually write the op-eds or their teams
do
under their no no no hold on here's my
question
because i've always thought that the
teams wrote it but then when you have
two big people
write it together like i feel like
there's a lot of i think they all get
together
have the ideas and then their teams
probably flush it out yeah but then you
gotta like collaborate two teams like it
like this
you submitted to the publication the
publication edits it for style and for
their style
i didn't know that um all right so on
the actual topic itself
no-brainer education is probably the
most powerful thing you know
but you know how you don't think like in
the us you're like okay we're not going
back to school in person it's okay we'll
just do it from like online learning duh
but like in other countries it's not as
simple and it's not
as accessible of course
that that that's why we're a developed
country and other countries are
developing we're not developing
you know how you always say that
education is the great equalizer if it
can be done
online but it's just for a lot of these
kids if you don't go in person you don't
get an education
you don't have to do it online i mean
look before the internet existed people
got it very educated the way they did it
was they got
knowledge got passed down from person
person to person now is it more
efficient is it more powerful is it all
of course the internet makes everything
so much better but i i don't think that
we want to get
a world where we have this binary view
like oh if it's
on the internet then it's real education
if it's not then it's not valuable
um but at the same time part of the
beauty of this is if you have an
internet connection you have access to
all this information
and so uh ultimately what um you know if
you go to like a
facebook a google whatever part of their
whole mission
um you know facebook internet.org
i was there when they were building some
of that it's just like just get people
the internet
if you get them internet access now
there's benefits to the tech companies
right obviously there's more people on
the internet they can make more money
but also it was just like you can really
really empower people
like just give them access to wikipedia
yeah right just this database full of
knowledge um
is pretty good and the other thing that
a lot of people don't uh
realize that you're just an american who
grew up here and never kind of really
traveled
internationally is women generally like
in afghanistan's a perfect example
go to the extreme example i think it's
after a certain age the taliban believes
that uh women shouldn't be educated
and it's like six or eight or like you
know and i'm probably getting some of
the date uh
the numbers wrong that's an extremist
group these are not the people
of afghanistan yes of course and so like
there are still
pockets in the world of like this very
very
um kind of uh like antiquated view of
the world
that i obviously don't agree with i
think most people don't agree with but i
do
think that we've seen time and time
again that educating a population in
general
leads to um you know great performance
and outcomes
but also specifically focusing on
educating women
um especially young girls can
significantly push forward an
entire society um but because
they're half the population not even
that but like i can't imagine
being in a place where you know like
think about it if you're not in school
your family's like okay well we're gonna
just like marry you off so
you can have a better life than being
single and uneducated
and you're you're being forced into
things in like early
early marriages early pregnancies all
that stuff it's just really well your
dad did your dad told me she's gonna
marry you
yeah yeah first time i remember he was
like she's gonna marry that's not funny
i was like
uh does a dowry come with this
kidding kidding kidding all right what's
up with george bush all right
i guys a dilemma what's up with w george
w bush you can attest to this
w stole my idea for a book
i don't know if he stole it he stole my
idea for a book
i think he beat you to it i don't know
george if you're listening call me
okay so my idea for a book was to do
to interview uh immigrant founders in
all 50 states and like small business
owners
and tell their stories well i don't want
to i don't wanna break it to you right
now i don't think he's doing that no he
is so he's releasing 43 portions of
immigrants okay it might not be the 50
states 43 immigrant
portraits that he painted himself
alongside their story
and it's called out of many one which is
a nod to
you know are there actually going to be
stories or is it just painting the
accompanying stories
oh all right well just so we're clear uh
he has a similar idea to you i don't
know no i think
george and george you gotta talk and
i like george are you gonna paint
because i've seen the stick figures you
paint and i don't know if people can be
buying the blue
i don't paint stick figures i draw them
by hand
what do you think he's painting with it
with his toes of course he paints
with by hand as well yeah but we got to
work on your artistic abilities no
worries
oh cause you're so artistic guys when
you see what we're about to do to this
studio area you guys are going to be
like wow look at his vision
wow look at his creativity wow look at
how awesome he is
if you've been with us since day one
since the bad acoustics the bad mics the
bad
no actually i'm not going to insult my
instant pot but
guys i literally i got this i got this
big ass microphone right here and i
can't get it to work yet but i'm going
to fix it i'm going to get it working
don't worry
i'm i'm on the case all right what's up
with your joke all right
ready if i just talk into the microphone
will that be good yeah go ahead
what do you call a row of rabbits
hopping away
a row of rabbits hopping away bunnies
no what a receding
hair line
like a hair are you trying to tell me
something no you have a green hair
you try to tell me yeah
look at how your hair's sticking out
right here i like that look at alfalfa
this way i gotta go this way yeah
alfalfa a little little thing going on
all right okay oh you see it you see it
yeah there we go
just so you guys know sometimes i like
to have a little fun no worries um all
right that's it for lunch monday today
we appreciate you guys watching but
while she's trying to get rich the rest
of us trying to get our lunch money
right
subscribe to the channel like the video
leave a comment
you know do all the things to help us
get to a hundred thousand we're so close
we're less than 4 000 subscribers away
from 100k
let's go 100k
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money
as much as we did and don't forget lunch
money is now sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block fight
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account there's
not very many places where you'll find
up to eight point six percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but eight point six percent
is pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends